you may have seen this story about
congressman and former trump white house
position
dr ronnie jackson a new report claims
while he was serving the white house
he bullied his staff made sexual
comments to female subordinates
and abused both alcohol and prescription
drugs while
on the job yeah very serious charges
well now some of his professional
colleagues are coming
to dr ronnie's defense and we have a
couple of them with us tonight
please welcome dr daniel dangler and dr
ted cushman thank you gentlemen for
coming on the show
oh no problem happy to defend dr ronnie
and uh
not a big deal conan but you
mispronounced my name okay i'm sorry
it's not pronounced cushman
no there's a comma missing it's dr kush
man
and my official medical title is dr
dangles the party md
he's never had a single party die in his
care
all right especially when i show up with
this and these party favorite condoms
okay i'm sorry are you two even real
medical doctors
oh of course we're real doctors we went
to medical school with dr ronnie
yeah it was the hardest six months of
our lives
but now i can legit do all the doctor
stuff i had already been doing for fun
like prescribing meds and sticking my
finger up your butt to check your
tonsils
you know what tonsils are in your throat
uh
i know i get in there pretty good
shots yeah i remember one time captain
ron
oh we called him captain ron because he
used to wear a tin can for a cap
so one time ronnie was super wasted and
he did the face off surgery
except with dongs i'm sorry dr ronnie
sounds like a terrible doctor
strongly disagree conan his knowledge of
viruses was
unmatched he knows all the strains covid
swine flu red banana donkey monster
sour patch kush mango haze the widow
maker stankosaurus rag
i get it i get it these are marijuana
foot party fudgy the whale slurricane
bar mitzvah cookie
channing tatum's toothbrush passage to
india we get it
we get it it's enough it's good wow brim
you need to bring down that blood
pressure is that how you talk to your
own primary care
party physician you know i don't have a
party physician
it's pretty clear that dr ronnie has a
real credibility problem
okay now let me just go on the record
and say that
dr captain ronnie jackson is a
consummate professional
and extremely capable physician your
honor
i'm sorry why did you just call me your
honor isn't this the legal deposition
for that time dr ronnie sewed some guy's
knees on backwards
no it is not oh snip wrong zoom we gotta
go
but first let's refuel yeah all right uh
dr
daniel dangler and dr ted kush
comma man